et si l'éclairage des routes et des
espaces publics était plus économique et
performant ce projet avait déjà été
annoncée par le ce même aujourd'hui pour
de nombreux maires les choses se
concrétisent un peu plus avec cette
conférence qui a pour objectif
d'éclairer leur lanterne enjeux et
modalités financement sont les
principaux points abordés
lorsqu'on a reçu dans ce projet avec
cette participation le plan de
financement
je parle de la commune de basse pointe
avec 100000 euros
la participation avec les élus on s'est
dit mais comment on va faire et
aujourd'hui pour un présente à cette
réunion pour entendre que les semaines
avec déjà anticipé sur cette
préoccupation sachant que le président
était aussi maire de gaspé l'homme avait
parfaitement compris la problématique
pour pouvoir bien visualiser les choses
regardez ce lampadaire des ampoules led
un éclairage connecté à la demande
de quoi réduire la facture d'électricité
de la commune et si le carbet on a déjà
installé sur sa plage d'autres villes
comme les trois ilets sont prêtes à
suivre le pas les trois les a sollicités
très rapidement le semaines pour être
intégré dans la phase une des sept
opérations donc tout l'intérêt que nous
portons cercle sonne comme une auto ici
c'est nous en avons nous avons beaucoup
de points lumineux
donc aussi bien sous les plages donc
l'intervention du responsable de lodève
nous intéresse quel éclairage m que sous
nos plages par rapport aux tortues
marines une transition énergétique en
marche pour une réduction de la
consommation entre 50 et 70%
il faut garder la lumière mais qu'elle
nous coûte moins cher que ce soit une
meilleure lumière qu'elle ne pollue pas
au top possible qu'elles protègent
l'environnement vous a parlé des tortues
sûrement et tout ça mis en oeuvre dans
un programme avec l'aide des quatre
partenaires que sont la ctm l'ademe et
df et le chemin le programme éclairage
public performant va se réaliser en deux
phases entre 2019 et 2023
sur plus de 60 mille points lumineux